meditation spirituality is the key to
unlock your inner finite human potential
[Music]
it's a perfect example of how inequality
emerges and we've seen this with Tesla
as well you know I've always wanted to
build my own software company saying
pretty much their cars autonomous it's
just getting over that last little bit
of do we really have the regulatory and
the social infrastructure to support
switching vehicles to autonomy
everybody's equal to begin with
everybody basically plays a random game
because monopoly is basically a random
game where instead of having huge
amounts of corn and soy being grown to
feed all these farm animals and massive
slaughter plants then and farms you then
would just have basically your own
localized clean meat production the cord
is written by the programmers and the
artists create the visuals so what does
a designer do and a designer's role is
to ultimately think of the player and to
make that experience be as enriching as
possible so so it's a random game so
what happens when everyone starts equal
and you play a random game one person
ends up with everything everyone else
stacks up at zero where they sold a
company just before I turn 24 what do
you ask you know children what they want
to be when they grow up mine was like an
inventor or like you know I want to own
a stop break
[Music]